we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to go to our next caller
from the 5 7 1 area code caller what's
your name and where you're calling from
let's start there my name is Vernon and
I'm calling from Northern Virginia ok
great what's uh what's going on today
yeah I would like to ask you what
criteria do you use in deciding what
news to present to your audience and put
on your show well it's I mean there's no
sort of simple answer to that but
basically I'm always sort of figuring
out from all of the news stories that
are out there
what stories should be on the regular
show what stories should be on the bonus
show and we want to try to have onion so
we've got an hour show right and we
could make the entire hour really long
key policy stories we could make the
entire hour sort of more salacious pop
type stories and we could you know
there's sort of any combination of
stories that the show could be I try to
go you know first segment the stories
that are more overtly political in
nature and timely stories in the second
segment we'll often go to stories that
are a little bit less of the of the top
stories of the day but still timely and
then we usually have an interview which
is scheduled several weeks in advance
and then at the end of the show is where
we'll usually squeeze in slightly more
popular culture oriented stories and
it's sort of an iterative process that
we're constantly tweaking and adjusting
if that makes sense
oh yeah it does thank you very much very
good thank you just add that because I
were an opinion show we make the choices
for stories that are going to be
something that we can comment on so if
it something very straightforward like
there's a missing plane or something we
can't really speculate that much about
it so I think that's another aspect to
it I'm glad you're adding that which is
that also we should it has to be a story
where we can actually do something with
it as opposed to just hey here's facts
and there's not even really that that
much to say about I think that's a good
point